bonjour bienvenue sur des donald
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs avec évidemment ce soir les
résultats du tournoi de hangars plus
forte on n'a jamais organisé en france
victoire éclatante de vladimir akopian
qui s'imposent facilement au programme
de cette émission donc résultats
analysés classement la partie explosive
vladislav tkachiev contre eux etienne
bacrot très belle partie jazz people une
interview laurent frayssinet tout cela
avec notre consultant sportif jean-luc
chavanon bonsoir jean luc bonsoir et loi
alors donc nous avons été faire un petit
reportage à enghien il se dégage dans ce
tournoi une impression de tranquillité
les joueurs ont l'air cool
oui les joueurs français donc qui qui
sont très très à l'aise donc à enghien
et qui sont très contents de jouer une
compétition d'un tel niveau
c'est clair c'est un très beau tournoi
pour eux c'est une très belle c'est un
très beau challenge puisqu'on sait que
les joueurs français n'ont pas toujours
été reconnu comme étant des tops joueurs
des très fort joueur et là ils ont eu
l'occasion effectivement de venir jouer
un tournoi du meilleur niveau vraiment
un tournoi de l'élite mondiale alors
pour commencer l'analyse du tournoi jean
luc et bien je pense qu'on va faire une
analyse du classement et pour cela vous
l'avez normalement devant vous il
devrait arriver le classement du tournoi
d'enghien donc à leur premier il s'agit
de voilà le voilà c'est l'arménien
akopian un petit mot sur ce joueur
donc ben l'arménien et a été vice
champion du monde en 99 il vient juste
de gagner le
l'us open de las vegas est donc là il
s'impose logiquement il et il est en
forme c'est l'homme en forme
l'homme en forme à copier en six points
sur neuf joël lautier cinq points et
demi deuxième tout seul très belle
performance
oui donc joël qui avait raté de peu la
qualification en quarts de finale pour
les quarts de finale de la coupe du
monde deux parties rapides à cannes qui
s'est imposée et qui a fait un très bon
tournoi 3 ex-aequo ensuite à cinq points
nous avons gagné barrail f etienne
bacrot et vendredi oui donc bas relief
petite forme
etienne bacrot donc un bon résultat même
s'il a eu ici il a perdu sept dernières
parties et vente velits donc un résultat
normal grâce à la normale en dessous de
son classement elo 6e greccio quatre
points et demi alors je crois qu'il
s'est très bien repris
oui green shoots c'est très très bien
repris puisque donc il était mal parti
et il est bien remonté en fin de temps
7e la star française laurent frayssinet
quatre points sur neuf
un résultat excellent donc pour un
premier tournoi à un tel niveau bon
c'est pas la moyenne mais c'est un bon
début
huitième position deux ex-aequo viktor
bologan et vladislav tkachiev avec trois
points et demi donc une double déception
surtout pour le joueur franco kazakh
vladislav quatre chefs qui réalise une
performance quand même pas bonne du tout
et dernier détaché
christian bauer 3 points donc bon petit
résultat mais bon la compétition est
très très dur et les français ne
pouvaient pas tous donc se hisser en
tête du classement évidemment
effectivement c'est vrai donc on notera
la superbe performance de vladimir
akopian qui s'impose avec un très beau
style des parties très propre deuxième
place joël lautier donc je vais le
dossier victorieux l'année dernière ne
fait que deuxième cette année mais le
niveau du tournoi c'est quand même
relevé considérable oui donc le tournoi
qui est qui est une catégorie 17 donc
c'est une grande première et donc joël
lautier qui qui a quand même très très
bien joué ils pouvaient éventuellement
gagner le tournoi puisque à la dernière
ronde il y avait sa présentation contre
contrat copine qui s'est soldé par un
match nul donc joël qui a dû tout essayé
pour gagner le tournoi mais qui n'est
pas arrivé je lautier donc bon qui fait
quand même une très très bonne
performance puisqu'il fait une
performance à presque deux mille sept
cents points elo ce qui n'est pas mal du
tout on a également recueilli enghien
jean-luc quelques images de ce tournoi
donc pour voir un peu l'ambiance et
on vous a concocté avec l'aide d'autres
réalisateurs donc françois un petit clip
vidéo avec la musique diagonale donc si
vous l'envoyez s'est tout de suite
voilà donc les images de enghien les
bains on a pu voir un plat dit cela
votre quatre chefs la tête complètement
rapatriés sur l'échiquier wydad qui
semblait très fatigué et viktor bologan
aussi qui s'est pris la tête dans ce
début de tournoi qui n'a pas compris ce
qui lui arrivait puisqu'il a commencé
par 0 sur 3 viktor bologan c'est celui
qu'on voit en dernier effectivement qui
a l'air un peu inquiet alors a noté jean
luc dans le fond de la salle comme dans
tous les grands tournois maintenant il y
à ces fameux écrans géants de projection
et il y avait aussi des commentaires par
casque infrarouge donc ça c'est le moyen
aux amateurs d'appréhender un peu les
échecs d'une façon plus simple
will et les organisateurs français donc
on compris le principe donc pour pour
faire le spectacle est il donc ils
mettent les moyens des écrans géants et
des commentaires par casque et sur
internet en direct
donc oui alors c'est la partie internet
on va y revenir donc il y avait des
commentaires par casque infrarouge donc
les joueurs s'équiper avec des écouteurs
il entendait les commentaires d'un deux
joueurs classés internationaux à 2200
2300 avec un sens pédagogique certain
donc c'était des commentaires très
accessible et ça c'est très bien et ils
ont également mis l'accent sur internet
puisque les parties était retransmise
sur le site officiel donc en guerre un
train free.fr est également sur le site
de sport à chaque point comme donc le
site de libération
avec les commentaires du grand maître
igor nataf donc maintenant on voit que
ça se développe vraiment non seulement
sur le terrain mais aussi sur l'internet
oui donc ce genre d'événement ne doit
pas passer ne doit pas passer à côté
donc de l'internet évidemment et c'est
très important donc d'utiliser utiliser
cette technologie pour pour informer les
joueurs sur le moment
parce qu'évidemment toute la france
vibrez donc devant cet événement il y
avait énormément de connecter alors
qu'est ce qui se passe sur internet et
bien tout simplement vous avez
l'échiquier vous avez à droite le chat
donc vous pouvez discuter avec d'autres
internautes vous taper au clavier vous
voyez les positions bref c'est vraiment
du live intégral avec tout le monde qui
vibre au après chaque coup après chaque
coup après chaque défaite après chaque
gaffe c'est vraiment donc dû de là c'est
beau spectacle et dans la salle et sur
internet
évidemment on a eu un petit problème
quand même à enghien jean-luc c'est que
les joueurs ne voulait plus répondre aux
interviews sachant qu'on les a déjà
pratiquement tous interviewé la dernière
fois oui c'est vrai des joueurs sont un
petit peu fatigué peut-être dans ce
tournoi il ya eu il ya eu
il eut beaucoup de tension il ya eu
beaucoup de retournements de situation
un bas relief qui a craqué en fin de
tournoi des dons les joueurs qui
finalement ont répondu à toutes les
questions qu'on attendait d'eux on avait
plus grand chose à ajouter tout à fait
alors bon évidemment on en a quand même
réussi à en attraper un
il s'agit donc du joueur qui venait de
gagner sa première partie dans le
tournoi donc ils étaient vraiment tous
contents d'ailleurs ça va se voir dans
cette interview il s'agit interview que
tu as fait jean-luc de laurent
frayssinet tout de suite en images à
enghien laurent roussel nous sommes en
direct d'enghien vous le connaissez
c'est leur offre et steen et ici ils
souffrent énormément mais il vient de
gagner wladys à quatre chefs et fait sa
rentrée dans le tournoi bonjour laurent
bonjour jean luc deux points et demi sur
sept c'est difficile mais c'est pas si
mal quand même
c'est difficile on sait pas très bien
c'est pas mon score c'est clair mais bon
vu comment ça s'est passé
j'ai beaucoup souffert en début de
tournoi et puis là je viens de battre
donc la discrète quatre chefs
donc c'est un très bon résultat mais
c'est vrai que au vu des parties je peux
espérer au moins la moyenne
il ya quelques mois etienne bacrot jouer
son premier faux retournera donc à
sarajevo
là tu joues un catégorie 17 j'aimerais
en savoir un petit peu plus donc sur tes
impressions dans un tel tournoi
bon les impressions c'est que les
joueurs sont évidemment très fort mais
j'ai pas l'impression que mon niveau et
leur niveau soit soit c'est différent
ils ont beaucoup plus d'expérience il
joue beaucoup des finales et finales
technique il est joue bien mieux que moi
j'ai perdu deux finales complètement nul
mais très technique contre bas reliefs
even velits donc ça me coûte deux fois
demi point et c'est vrai que bon je suis
pas je suis impressionné mais c'est
surtout au niveau
la différence se fait au niveau
technique et au niveau des nerfs donc
voilà aujourd'hui tu viens de battre le
playboy des échecs
comment ça s'est passé disons que j'ai
égalisé après l'ouverture avec les noirs
n'ont que j'avais très bien préparé mon
ouverture est bon il n'ya pas il est lui
non plus n'a pas un très bon score il
avait moins avant la partie donc ils
avaient deux ennemis sur six et ils
voulaient absolument battre il a pris
trop de risques et souvent quand on
prend trop au risque et b ça se retourne
contre nous et on perd
en freyssinet donc en direct à enghien
et bien dit c'est effectivement bien
débrouillé puisque après cette victoire
contre 27,4 chef il a repris confiance
jean-luc ah oui laurent qui est qui a
fait une remontée fantastique dans un
tel niveau de la compétition puisqu'il
avait un point et demi sur six et il
termine avec quatre points sur neuf donc
il
il termine donc avec deux ennemis sur
trois ce qui est quand même incroyable
une victoire contre bologne à la
dernière une victoire contre donc
vladislav tkachiev nul contre joël
lautier pas mal oui c'est très très bien
pas mal pour la fin donc voilà pour ce
qui est de laurent frayssinet on a déjà
commenté son résultat c'est clair on va
bientôt passer à notre à notre parti
commenté
mais avant ça jean luc il y a il ya une
petite séquence sympa on en reparlera
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure dans le chas
people qui s'est passé dans le repas que
nous avons fait avec les joueurs à la
fin du tournoi et donc là tu as fait une
petite interview un peu particulière
pour parler justement de la star
française etienne bacrot oui donc oui
j'ai voulu un petit peu mettre l'accent
donc sur l'aspect décontracté donc du
tournoi un petit peu puisque les joueurs
sont là finalement il s'essaie des
jeunes joueurs et ils passent donc leur
soirée ensemble et on voit qu'il ya une
équipe de france très très soudée ce qui
promet donc pour les prochaines les
prochaines compétitions par équipes tout
à fait alors tout de suite on va
l'envoyer il s'agit de jean-luc chavanon
sur le billard de l'échiquier diagonale
spécial enghien nous allons donc passer
sur le billard donc l'analyse de ce
tournoi donc un tournoi à la française
les gens france est donc très très en
forme pour cette édition est donc on
l'espère etienne bacrot victorieux dans
deux jours voilà père etienne bacrot
victorieuse ce ne fut pas le cas jean
luc puisqu'il a perdu la dernière partie
contre vladislav tkachiev un vladislav
dans playboy de l'échiquier qui s'est
réveillée d'une façon totalement
fantastique
ça va être le sujet de la partie
commentée de la semaine on va donc
mettre l'échiquier est tout de suite
commenté les coûts puisque on va passer
à l'action donc voilà donc des cartes
des quatre jours dès qu'on verra les
chiens on va passer à l'action on va
quand même présenter rapidement donc
ladislav qui a un style agressif
vla qui a un style agressif qui est un
joueur donc très spectaculaire et qui
d'habitude donc joue joue quand même un
petit peu plus solide mais il était
tellement ils étaient à la recherche de
l'exploit dans ce tournoi il avait mal
démarré il chercher l'exploit chercher
l'exploit donc bon il s'est repris donc
c'est un joueur très agressif etienne
bacrot c'est un très bon défenseur
donc c'est cette partie c'est un petit
peu la tacc contre la défense est
exactement donc c'est un petit peu
l'attaqué contre la défense c'est une
position que vlad connaît très très bien
et est donc voilà donc on va suivre un
petit peu donc d4 d5
vous voyez donc ça c'est tout à fait
normal c'est symmetrix et c'est une dame
solide pour les noirs voient la c4 c6 la
défense slave donc l'objectif de cette
défense et de tenir les cases blanches
au centre a priori côté noir est en tout
cas d'équilibrer la position cavaliers
ces trois cavaliers f 6 e 3 e 6 donc
c'est une défense celui slave donc les
noirs donc pour l'instant verrouille le
centre mais ils ont l'intention plus
tard donc comme on va le voir de se
libérer plus plus activement alors à
noter un petit détail dans cette
ouverture si on revient de coups avant
pourquoi est ce que les blancs jouent
eux trois alors que ça enferme le
phocéen est bien c'est que sur cavaliers
f3 le coût qui est naturel dans cette
position bien il ya peu on prend ces
quatre avec une véritable défense lave
qui est donc pas facile
disons que c'est une langue différente
la vladislav choisi de ne pas laisser le
tueur en prison qu'ils jouent aux trois
ans ferme en voulant termes en sont fous
et après aussi son arrivée dans quelque
chose de très théorique très connu la
fameuse semi slave cavaliers f3 qui
avait libé 17
donc tout ça c'est très connu c'est très
très connue donc fou des trois donc vlad
qui déplogue qui développent ces pièces
il aura l'intention plus tard
éventuellement de se libérer par trois
ou quatre mais il termine d'abord son
développement il va il va rauque et
probablement d'autres cadres donc pour
mettre une pression central
supplémentaire la dépense et 4 c'est un
coup responsable la priorité reste les
quatre responsables donc un coût qui
abandonne provisoirement le centre
puisque donc le plan des singles
contrôle plus la case de 4 mai mais dans
cette position on va voir qu'après après
quelques coups les noirs vont gagner
quelques temps pour développer leurs
pièces donc là il en profite pour jouer
b5
donc c'est en fait c'est on peut dire
que c'est une session positionnelle
puisqu'on a donné le centre en revanche
on va commencer à gagner du temps donc
c'est etienne joue dynamique dans cette
position etienne commence par jouer
dynamique dont qui il commence par
attaquer le fou donc il gagne un temps
sur le fou qui donc les blancs on ramène
rapatrient leurs fonds en d3a si cela
est yann consolide donc ce pion b5 pour
préparer éventuellement la libération du
centre par c6 c5 c6 c5 qui donnerait
donc a priori si les blancs prenaient en
c5 une structure de son symétrique
donc ça sera un succès total de
l'ouverture des noirs exactement puisque
les noirs ont gagné quelques temps et
maintenant ils menacent des changes et
la dernière le dernier pion au centre
donc on voit que ça si ça défend b5 et
ça permet ces 5
c'est un raisonnement tout simple donc
c'est on est encore dans la grande ligue
terrorisme on est encore dans la grande
dignité aurique de cette défense semi
slave variante mayrand exactement vente
mayrand je crois que ça date du match
karpov cornouaille qui a lieu à mayran
oui donc à merano plus exactement on
habite à loïc
voilà donc une variante qui a déjà pas
mal d'années
le 3 e 4 1 donc là une remarque jean-luc
les blancs ne rock pas il ouvre d'abord
la position alors qu'en principe on dit
fort ok d'abord répondre à la pression
après un oui mais dans cette position
donc les blancs décide décide de 10 vite
et peut-être des lignes d'autres lignes
donc des lignes par becca tout d'autres
possibilités ils veulent attaquer tout
de suite le centre
cette position ils peuvent se libérer
roque et un coût plus tard ça changerait
pas grand chose oui tout à fait on peut
dire qu'ils ont quand même une avance de
développement donc c'est pas grave
qu'ils aient par ok puisque les noirs
n'ont pas évoqué non plus donc que trois
ou quatre c'est en fait c'est du détail
théorique c'est à dire que les deux
joueurs connaissent très bien cette
position petit rock est une autre
possibilité mais vladislav choisi au 4
c'est un choix parmi il parmi un autre
ces 5 2 mais tiennent donc la pression
pour un caractère un peu sauvage la
position prend un caractère un peu
sauvage entre les lits blancs dispose de
deux réactions donc le coût des quatre
des cinq donc qui est une vieille une
vieille possibilités je crois que karpov
jouer ce genre de coup et tout en même
en deux parties karpov et sur des quatre
dessins que le vieux coup serait donc
ces cinq c4
donc ces cinq c4 et qui mène dans une
position compliquée on va bien détaillés
on va on va bien montrer ce qui se passe
dans cette position il ya un problème
concret pour l'instant c'est que les
noirs menace vraisemblablement de jouer
pions prend pions je leur fais puis on
prend pions avec un échange au centre
suis trouvé cette suite d'une position
qui simplifie et qui tendrait vers les
qualités exactement
donc les blancs contre ça on plusieurs
réactions possibles ils peuvent soit
joué des 5 c'est à dire sa garde la
dissymétrie dans l'opposition ça ne sera
pas une position symétrique soit joué le
coup de vladislav donc le coup eux 5
alors là il y a eu un petit problème
technique un petit problème technique
on va en un instant récupérer la
situation jean luc si j'y arrive puisque
alors un petit instant voilà rien nous y
revenons poupe
donc nous emballons pas donc voilà 5le
couche le coup choisi par vladislav donc
alors sur re5 donc c'est simple c'est
que cinq attaques lecavalier en f 6 oui
et ce qui se passe c'est que le cavalier
alors m6 n'a pas de gaz naturel les
quatre centrales sont et en contrôle et
donc par le cavalier c3 la case des 5
donc qu'est les dessins que c'est
possible c'est possible mais ce serait
mauvais probablement à cause de
cavaliers prend prend des 5
oui et elle est et puis on prend et la
structure blanche serait favorable les
blancs pour n importe quel moment donc
après un coup comme petit rock on
pourrait préparer aussi sous cavaliers
g5 et des coups très très menaçant pour
le roi noir qui c'est à dire que ce
options aux cinq en fait est un énorme
problème pour les noirs puisqu'ils
peuvent plus remettre leurs cavaliers 17
ans 9,6 la casse de défense donc le roi
le roi potentiellement détiennent bacro
sort trouvé de mal protéger
effectivement d'un point de vue plus
général la structure du pont des besoins
plus compact exactement
donc ce n'est pas vraiment une option de
jouer qu'avec des cinq dans cette
position donc les noirs auront recours
dans cette position à une ligne un peu
plus sauvage qui essaient prend des cats
et prend des quatre c'est donc un coup
dit intermédiaire un coin tamedia donc
le cavalier à m6 est en prise c'est vrai
mais lecavalier en c3 est également
emprise
donc s'ils ont pu reprendre à m6 on peut
en comprendre un lecavalier en c3 est là
donc les blancs décide
d'échangés mais d'une manière un peu
spécial donjon cavaliers pro b 5
alors ça devient assez compliqué à
expliquer avec des mots simples
donc on va montrer le court il ya des
lampions cavaliers prend des cinq encore
une fois dont les blancs acceptent
d'échanger les pièces puisqu'on voit que
le sur apprend b5 et les noirs et les
blancs prendrait donc en f 6 mai ils
veulent fragiliser la structure des
pions noirs allèles dame puisqu'il y
aurait un seul petit pion en b 5
oui tout à fait d'autant plus que le
problème jean luc c'est qu'après pions
prend b 5 pions prend m6 on ne peut pas
vraiment reprendre ni avec le enfin on
peut pas reprendre avec le cavalier ni
avec la dame sinon il reste sous
pression b5
ça c'est problématique donc
effectivement ici faut pas accepter ça
il faut jouer encore un coup dans le
même ordre d'esprit c'est à dire que bon
il faudrait je lui parle de lui-même il
ferait jouer donc cavalier il faut
ajouter les points 5
voilà donc où encore une fois difficile
à expliquer on met un cavani en prise
volontairement mais c'est pas grave
puisqu'on a éliminé avec ça le pion qui
attaque et notre autre cavalier et donc
on se prépare à reprendre le cavalier b5
avec notre pions donc pour l'instant au
niveau matériel c'est égal et chaque
camp à une caisse en prison voilà donc
la halle et blanc décide finalement de
simplifier en prenant aux cinq
ras-le-bol l'explication qui à l'époque
et valier puis on prend bessin qui
maintien en pro b 5
hélas les blancs on refuse de prendre le
pion bessin qu'ils jouent petit rock
alors on va quand même expliquer la
ligne théorique puisque on est encore
dans la théorie pendant très longtemps a
été le coup franc b5 et il ya eu un
énorme débat théorique dans cette
position un débat qui n'est probablement
pas fini qui commence à peine mais le
juste mentionné de trois coups oui donc
fou 17 cavaliers prend 17 et la dame à
cinq échecs
voilà on ne reprend pas on en droit de
s'interroger on voit que donc la dame
attaque le roi en a eu un
la dame en a 5 et el al et à l'attack le
fou en b 5
donc après ça continue par
éventuellement cités des oeufs et dame
prend b5 dame prend b saint vallier
prend la fuite et point fuite et avec
une position très compliqué position
extrêmement compliqué les noirs vont
perdre le droit de rock mais c'est pas
grave puisque les blancs peuvent par ok
non plus bref
céline théorique et c'est extrêmement
complexe juste à titre informatif on
vous donne cette variante mai
ladislav choisi autre chose voilà donc
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que donc
cette ouverture 7,7 défense mayrand
donne lieu à de nombreux débats
théoriques
c'est clair petit rock on ne reprend pas
enlevé cinq en revanche maintenant
menace de le prendre assez méchamment
puisque les normes vous aurez plus est
contre eux pointent damas un échec
puisque laurent n'est plus à la case où
ils étaient avant
oui donc les noirs vont vont tout
résoudre en un coup dam des cinq dames
des 5 alors un coup qui attaquent le
kode5 qui défend le clan bessin l'option
b 5 et en même temps qui construit parce
que on peut voir qu'après tout bessette
et d'amd 5
on a fait une batterie qui se pointent
clairement sur le roi blanc vers le roi
blanc donc le coup a priori parfait
attaque défense et construction un beau
coup de centralisation de dames
oui donc là beaucoup d'atouts le seul
petit défaut de cette position c'est le
roi noir le roi noir pour l'instant n'a
pas trouvé d'abris donc
donc les blancs continuent leur
développement par dame 2 parce que les
tiennes un 'plus' sinon etienne à un
pion de plus d'1 m 2 on joue dame de on
attaque le pion b5
alors on défend claudio 5 j'allais dire
on attaque le plan des cinq attaques
l'option des cinq donc ou qui attaque et
qui défend on fait communiquer les tours
oui ça construit ça construit donc le ca
termine plut plus ou moins bien le
développement et donc on place une pièce
qui pourrait être utile pour plus tard
pour l'attack davodeau donc fou à six
dès lors jean luc je crois que tu as le
contact et vladislav tkachiev par
téléphone pour nous aider dans cette
analyse
et il a parlé deux fois 6 il a dit que
joël lautier avait joué autour des 8
dans la même position
donc le etienne bacrot contre je veux le
voilà donc etienne bacrot connais très
bien cette position il l'a jouée par
équipe l'année dernière donc lors du
match cannes clichy il a joué donc
tourbe et 8 dans cette position donc
dans cette position là joël estienne
lacourt avait choisi la facture des vite
il avait gagné contre
contre joël lautier vlad évidemment qui
joue dans la même équipe qui tienne été
témoin de cette partie était quand même
assez
douter quand même de la valeur du
soukous tourbez vite probablement vlad a
dû trouver une parade à ce coup tombé
huit et étienne fort justement a décidé
de changer de variantes donc fois six
nouveautés détiennent pour surprendre
vlad et en même temps parce que tourbeux
8 n'était pas forcément le meilleur coût
nouveauté détiennent mais pas nouveauté
la théorie puisque c'est le coup
classique c'est le coût qui est reconnu
par la théorie donc c'est encore
théorique ici vladislav tkachiev donc là
c'est très logique
ce qui fait maintenant dans cette
position et bien il sort ses pièces il
termine son développement voilà donc pas
refouler singla d'un pion - il faut
qu'ils activent ces pièces le plus
possible oui puisqu'on sait bien qu'avec
un peu moins si on attend et qu'on ne
fait rien et bien on va finir par perdre
donc il faut être très dynamique est là
sur quoi vlad va baser son son truc
ça va être une attaque sur le roi
exactement donc là il a développé la
dernière pièce
dans sa position et maintenant ils
s'apprêtent à jouer le coup f2f 4 suivi
de f4 f5
le bélier le fameux bélier qui le coup
du bélier qui le coup du bélier qui va
être là pour pour déstructurer son
adversaire ils veulent des structures
non mais c'est normal parce que pourquoi
une fois qu'on a poussé ses pions en
effet qu'on l'a échangé c'est à dire
éventuellement qu'on a pris un v6 et
bien on voit qu'on a les colonnes
ouverte la colonne f et la colonne eux
qui seront donc disponibles pour deux
tours blanches et braqué vers les pions
faible des noirs si on ajoute ça avec la
diagonale b1 h7
voilà donc tous les trois très fort
voilà donc ça fait beaucoup d'atouts
énormément d'atouts donc des
compensations en perspective pour ce
pion maintenant bon f4 f5 n'est pas
encore joué c'est etienne bacrot qui
défend donc la partie commence la partie
commence donc foule cette fosse est
l'attaqué contre la défense donc fawcett
le coup de défense
ladislav f4 voilà normal le coude
attaque petit an aucun petit rock on n'a
pas peur on n'a pas peur dans cette
position voilà à priori à une
combinaison qui paraît évidente mais qui
n'a pas été jouer c'est le coup-franc
cavani f6 jean-luc up avec l'idée que
par exemple sur fou prend et bien on
peut jouer le couffo 4 ça c'est possible
qui a l'air de ramasser en tout cas une
qualité ans habite mais je crois que ça
marche pas ce match probablement pas à
cause de la petite astuce dame c5 mc5
exactement dame c5 qui vais donc
l'adamant donc le roi blanc presque en
échec mais il ya un pion de vent et
maintenant si le fou vient prendre la
tour jean luc et bien on ne reprend pas
le fou on joue donc terminant sais pas
c'est pas tout à fait ça en fait c'est
bon alors jean-luc je vais donc te dire
la solution du problème puisque c'était
pas vraiment ça surtout au cas très bien
on joue simplement le ku'damm des six
bon je sais je sais plus non plus alors
en fait une question qu'on peut se poser
je me rappelle me laisse reposer pendant
la partie avoir eu la solution mais là
tout de suite je ne sais plus alors
donc la question reste ouverte sur
fonction voilà ils sont fous cat
on peut peut-être joué je pense avoir
trouvé donc encore le biz saisirai c'est
dans la provoc sur faut quatre peut-être
b5 bi 4b 5b 4 voilà et on voit si le
froid this attack la torre fin et la
dame a eu deux l'idée était basé là
dessus c'est dire qu'après des 5 b 4 on
voit donc il ya un doublé en fait il le
faut effectivement qui attaque et la
dame et la tour mais les noirs font
paralyse attaque et la dame et la tour
donc au final ce sera un échange de
pièces et ça c'est pas bon pour ladislav
puisque moyen de pièces est bien plus
option que de - va se faire sentir
donc cette combinaison n'était pas
possible on peut pas jouer au foot pro f
6 il faut continuer la tacc on peut
jouer avec 4 f 5 mai vladislav à trouver
autre chose quelque chose de plus punchy
peut-être oui oui donc on peut jouer f4
f5 mais dans cette position ça
risquerait peut-être d'ouvrir les lignes
avantageusement au noir qui pourrait
peut-être prendre un f5 et amener une
tour sur la colonne eux donc la wla de
amène une tour ils jouent tous rêvent 3
et 7 tours f3 sur la troisième rangée
aura une action très désagréable
puisqu'elle a la possibilité d'aller sur
la case d3 et la case h32 possibilité
pour la tour 2 cases qui sont braqués en
face du rock noir directement orientée
vers le rock noir c'est très très
menaçants comme manoeuvre clairement
donc ici après tour f3 et bien etienne
le roi de la défense geoff hoon et c'est
donc en fait ils recentrent un peu ses
pièces maintenant que le fou des trois
peut plus prendre l'option b 5 avec
échec en tout cas eh bien il est temps
de se remettre de replacer le x 6
puisque cela plusieurs avantages d'un
déjà ça fait la batterie des retours
vers l'option g2 et en même temps ça ou
la torah vite vers le pion à deux et ça
évite aussi fou prend ainsi suivi de
feux 4 qui maintenant est possible ça
évite également francis 8 x 4 vad
il se laisse pas dévié par cette
histoire d'options b5
dijoux tour les trois très logique
ça va directement sur le roi jean luc
louis vlad donc qui avait perdu ses
trois dernières parties je crois à
l'intention de faire quelque chose
d'extraordinaire dans cette partie bah
là il en a marre ben là il vient de
prendre trois défaites consécutives
il a envie de se refaire c'est logique
puisqu'il à 2700 points il fait partie
des meilleurs joueurs de ce tournoi et a
aucune raison qu'il a à payer une partie
il joue donc tout rejet 3 il commence à
y voir une concentration de caisse
blanche qui devient assez sympathique et
qui va pas tarder à exploser alors on va
le voir après peut-être un coup donc
détiennent des croquis et qui sent pas
vraiment venir le danger tours fc 8 on
n'a pas l'impression que ça soit un coût
de défense c'est a quand même un coup de
défense puisqu'on constate que dans
cette position quand même étienne donc
dans ce type de position quand le roi
noir est extrêmement menacée c'est
toujours utile de garder quelques cases
de fuite
donc là le roi noir envisage une fuite
en avant et le roi noir et envisage
éventuellement une fuite en avant c'est
quelque chose de très important dans ce
type de position est alors d'ailleurs la
combinaison du jour donc entraîner votre
intuition voilà donc petite pause
tactique alors 5 4 3 2 1 x 10 7
voilà l'autre en achète donc le fameux
coup le fameux fou prend achète un coup
d' attaque récurrents jean-luc voilà
donc foot pro h7 on constate que le
cavalier f6 ne peut pas prendre le
fourrage c'est tout simplement parce que
le fou en recette serait pris oui tout à
fait donc ça sera donc un échange de
pièces et que sur roy prend h7 les
blancs l'entrée les blancs vont terminer
vont gagner très très facilement en
jouant fou prend m6 faut prendre si ce
fut bref si cela on a éliminé le fameux
cavale et de défense dans souvenez vous
c'est toujours ça cavaliers qui est la
pièce qui défend extrêmement bien donc
après fou prend fou il ya maintenant
quelques poules maquette envers hugo
vandamme h 5 échecs suivi de roy g8 et
d'amour wife cet échec d'un probable cet
échec
roy et droit je suis toi moi j'ai trois
tours h3c terminé on voit qu'avec la
tourelle adam et bien on donne le vat
variante une première variante qui
démontre bien que la position blanche
peut se déplier comme un ressort donc
après fous pour acheter
etienne joue le coup
logique roy fuite roy et fuite ça c'est
normal donc etienne 120 c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'on avait prévu tout à
l'heure pour l'instant ils pensent que
ce n'est pas si grave parce que comme
ces pièces c'est tour sont placés sur
des colonnes ouverte
il a des pièces assez active donc ils
pensent que ce n'est peut-être pas si
grave que les pièces que les noirs ne
vont pas trouver la solution mais la wla
donc à jouer un coup dont il n'est pas
sûr de la de la justesse c'est ce qu'il
m'a dit par téléphone
mais mais qui est très très intéressant
et qui encore très très spectacle c'est
fou h6 alors ce coût est curieux mais à
noter quand même si on revient dans la
position précédente
on voit que ce fou g5 et bien on sait
plus trop ce qu'il fait s'il prend m6 il
ya fou prend cavaliers et la position
nord sera très solide a donc il envie de
remplacer son fou et le met en rage 6
alors sacré jean luc tout de suite une
menace directe on veut prendre l'option
g7 soit avec le fou soit avec la tour ça
c'est inacceptable pour etienne il n'a
pas d'autre choix que de dire ah ben là
des biens écoute je prends ton fou
qu'est ce que t'as vu voilà qu'est ce
que tu as vu et lavelanet à vue
probablement le plus beau coup de la
partie le plus beau coup de la partie
c'est bien le plus beau coup de la
partie donc là on va vous laisser trois
secondes donc 3 3 2 1 d'un match sac
d'un match 5
damages stocks mais la dame emprise
jean-luc mais ça on verra que c'est pas
trop grave et menaçant même tandem
preuve cet échec et mat
voilà donc une menace incroyable donc
sur cavaliers prend dame tout g8 échec
et mat
donc là on va le montrer cavale et prend
dame est une possibilité mais il ya
toujours huit matches tout simplement
votre le roi ne peut plus s'en aller il
est enfermé
donc c'est le match en main qu'on aime
bien damages 5 la dame est en prise mais
ne peut pas être prises donc encore une
fois etienne ne doit doit prendre sa
valise et s'en allait il joue au roi 8
dans cette position alors roy vite pour
l'instant etienne a quand même et pièces
de plus donc s'il attaque de vlad ne
marche pas et bien etienne va gagné 3,8
d'un preuve cet échec est roi des 8,3
des beats tout ça c'est fort c'est pour
etienne bacrot maintenant il faut que
vlad continue son attaque donc vlad va
faire intervenir sa tour g3 donc elle
défend le g2 et mais elle peut aussi
attaquer donc le fou un set en se
plaçant sur la case j'essaie
alors quand tu dis que la tour des fonds
g2 depuis j'ai trois hôtes aussi depuis
g7
c'est très important puisqu'on voit que
les noirs ou un duo fouda mais que si le
plan n'est pas défendu et bien ces dames
pranger deux matches voilà baiser de la
mort directe est dans cette position
etienne bacrot a fait a fait l'erreur
il a fait l'erreur qui lui a coûté donc
la partie il aurait pu il aurait pu
continuer la partie en jouant le ku'damm
des cinq des six oui ce coup-là dam des
cinq des six la d'amendés 6 défend le x
e set et défend le pion aux six au lieu
de secouer tiennent à jouer dame ces
cinq voiliers alors donc ce que ça
change c'est que ce coup donc défend le
faut cette sas était la priorité des
noirs mais ne défend pas le pion aux 6
voilà donc la position est extrêmement
compliqué et etienne a s'est trompé il
n'a pas joué le meilleur coup et après à
noter qu'il ya une menace quand même
assez vicieux sde etienne bacrot ici un
c'est que s'ils veulent a dit cela joue
un coup anodin a par exemple un proche
de 6 on va quand même le mentionner eh
bien je crois qu'il ya maintenant
quelques coups jean-luc si je ne dis pas
d'erreur avec des trois des quatre
détroit qui est très très fort
évidemment le roi doit venir en une fois
dans cette position ce n'est pas encore
matt mois il devenir enfin puisque s'il
vient sur la case achat
eh bien nous avons le maître du couloir
avec d'alternate donc en revanche si le
roi bien sûr la case f1 là il ya
beaucoup de possibilités mais notamment
le courroux des cinq équipes qui va donc
consolider la défense autour du roi noir
qui va permettre donc a été anormalement
a priori de s'en sortir mais vlad a
trouvé mieux parce qu'il veut pas en
fait laissé son roi partir comme ça du
mauvais côté entre guillemets puisque là
le roi pas du bon côté
il est vraiment dans le vent oui oui et
puis il veut pas laisser donc ce pion
des puisque là aussi fou des cinq ou six
des trois des deux est le pion à vent
serait très très dangereusement donc
vlad décide puisque la manoeuvre la
menace de vlad une des menaces de
blattes ces deux de pique et le fou
cette part cavalier e 5 e 5 g 6 ah ça
c'est une menace c'est une menace très
importante puisque le fou aux 7 ne peut
pas quitter cette case puisqu'il défend
le cavalier af si ce oui on voit que les
placements sont imbriquées les unes dans
les autres et il peut pas aussi quitter
cette place puisque la tour angers7
contrôler la septième rang
et la fameuse septième rangée de
présenter ce qui ce qui laisserait donc
aux blancs de nombreuses possibilités
pour mater le roi noir
oui tout à fait donc il joue h3 un petit
coup un petit coup il a une piste de
moins
c'est vrai mais dans cette position les
noirs ne peuvent pas réagir utilement et
il va placer tout simplement son rang h2
en sécurité d'accor donc en fait c'est
un réflexe il s'est arrêté net dans son
attaque
il s'est dit je mets mon rang sécurité
d'abord et ensuite je poursuis mon
attaque qui finalement va être imparable
exactement c'est comme curieuse c'est un
coût d'une extrême lucidité on peut le
dire puisque dans cette position il faut
avoir confiance dans son jeu de pièces
pour pour décidé de temporiser puisque
on a du matériel en moins alors
temporisé ça veut dire prendre son temps
prendre son temps temporisé tout
simplement prendre son temps savoir que
le matériel peut revenir plus tard ce
n'est pas le plus important
tout reprend pion à 2
coût 2 etienne une petite tactique pour
essayer de faire diversion puisque après
tout reprend à 2 etienne ferait
probablement dames c'est un échec ça n'a
pas été jouer ce coup ça n'a pas été
joué il ferait probablement dames c'est
un échec et le roi en h2 n'aurait plus
d'abris puisque la dame au c1 pourrait
prendre le pion à f4 c'est à dire que si
le roi bien ce qu'on enlève de soi en h2
la dame c1 vient prendre le pion au f4
faisant échec au roi où qu'ils soient et
ensuite on peut ramasser
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on va tout
simplement mater le roy on va mater
droit puisque on va descendre la tour
voilà exactement la tour va intervenir
on aura deux dames et tour en attaque et
ça ça fait pas de cadeau puisque aussi
le fou bessette qui garde un oeil
toujours sur cette position donc ici il
ya matt rapide très clairement donc tout
reprend à deux points de tactique d'
etienne bacrot qui au passage crée une
menace ils menacent ce futur grand tour
dont il ramasse un pion et il fait une
menace
c'est lors de travaux assez fort ça a
l'air d'être un coup assez fort mais mes
vlad joue encore un coup extrêmement
lucide c'est tour des 1
il prend son temps vraiment décidément
c'est une attaque persistante qui al'air
irrésistible envie tout à fait dans sa
position de la ddt
il prend son temps là il a plusieurs
menaces directes
ils menacent éventuellement donc dame
ils menacent tout reprend des cats échec
temps prendrait quatre échecs je ne
crois pas jean-luc puisqu'il aurait dame
prend 3,4 oui notre échec
dans ce livre elle menace pas tout à
fait ça il a indiqué j'ai six menace qu
alger 6 dame prend 1,6 il menace
également donc on va on va rappeler les
menaces des blancs dans cette position
si on y arrive ça paraît pas gagné ah
non on n'y arrive pas le cavalier de 5
menace devenir angers 6 attaquants le
fou aux 7es ramassant le faut cette
autre menace jean-luc donc tu l'as dit
la dame en rêve cette menace de prendre
l'option en 6 avec des menaces à venir
avec des menaces à venir des grosses
menaces à venir avec eux il y avait
plein de très très forte menace ça c'est
les deux menaces principales les blancs
à noter que donc elles peuvent être
évitées
d'ailleurs etienne et vite
le coût d'un projet 6 oui etienne
levitte le ku'damm prend aussi s'il joue
donc tam des six dans cette position
mais malheureusement cavaliers g6
l'accueil g6 c'est un coût qui fait mal
c'est un coût qui fait mal et tiennent
ne peut pas bouger son fouet cette comme
on l'a précisé tout à l'heure donc alors
est ce qu'on peut dire que dame des 6es
lagaf la véritable gaffe puisqu'on a vu
qu'une première fois donc la première
fois qui est un ajout d'anne decis non
il aurait dû jouer dam des six mais il a
joué dame c5 est ce que la secoue dame
décide quand même à l'air à l'air
perdant pourquoi parce que il ne part
pas cette menace qui est g62 vladislav
tkachiev et après quelle g6 là on pense
qu'il est à ce moment là vraiment
perdant week-end c'est vrai mais quoi
faire d'autre dans cette position on
peut imaginer beaucoup de défense quand
même on peut imaginer par un tour prend
b2 mais surtout on prend b2 il y a un
gros problème c'est tout simplement le
coup cavalier e 5 des trois donc tour
prend b2 c'est une possibilité qu'avait
eu cinq en d3 fourchette fourchette
voilà donc le cavalier en d3 qui
attaquent la dame en c5 et la tour en b2
à noter qu'en cas les prendre à la tour
d2 il défendra la tour d un il est très
important puisque ça évite un coup comme
dame c2 et dames ces deux qui ne serait
pas possible à cause des dames pro cet
échec et mat aussi d'un pro cet échec et
mat alors effectivement donc en fait on
vient déstabiliser cette dame on va
ramasser rassemblement la tour b 2 donc
ici c'est terminé voilà c'est terminé ça
va très vite
ça va très vite donc tous retombés 2
n'est pas vraiment possible dans cette
position il faut trouver un autre ou de
défense et peut-être que etienne bacrot
s'est effondré tout simplement dans
cette position peut-être que les
défenses sont très dur à trouver
en tout cas d'après vlad donc cette
position est déjà gagnant pour les
blancs oui d'après vlad donc l'erreur a
déjà été fait les les noirs dont pas de
défense n'ont pas de défense
alors ça paraît toujours un petit peu
magique quand même de dire voilà le
joueur a sacrifié une pièce qu'il a fait
ses échecs
après il a il a rien fait c'est dire
qu'il a mis son roman sécurité il a
ramené sa tour en jeu et le jour avec
une pièce de plus n'a rien pu faire
comme un peu curieux alors est ce qu un
fondement positionnelle énorme dans
cette attaque est évidemment guillien
forme impressionné on voit donc deux
pièces blanches qui sont placés sur la
septième rangée
donc c'est la tour et la dame évidemment
un cavalier en avant postes sur la case
eux cinq une tournée sur une colonne
ouverte en face du roi voilà donc on va
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya une masse on va
on va faire dans le
donc et un roi blanc qui est plus ou
moins à l'abri
oui tout à fait donc par opposition aux
pièces noires qui phares avant sont
quand même beaucoup moins bien placé par
opposition pièce noire et par opposition
au roi noir le roi noir qui est dans le
vent les pièces noires qui ont du mal à
se défendre on voit que le fourbe et
cette emprise qui n'est pas défendu que
donc il ya ça que lecavalier 6 paraît il
et emprises défendre uniquement par le
fawcett qui lui même est en prise bref
l'un dans l'autre bien on n'arrive pas
vraiment à s'y retrouver dans cette
position
les noirs n'ont plus vraiment de défense
donc c'est une combinaison que vladislav
a commencé en fait en jouant fou prend
1,7 et fois ci c'est vraiment fois
justice le coup déterminant
oui donc vlad a commencé cette
combinaison en jouant fourrage cet
échouage six puisqu'il n'était pas
obligé de jouer fou h6 tout à fait donc
là on va voir quand même la conclusion
après dam des six cabines g6 attaque le
faut et 7 points s'est hissé en roches
la vanille g6 qui était la menace
principale puisque je pense que si si si
etienne avait joué d'autres coûts que
d'amd 6 cela devrait probablement joué
cavalli g6 quand même tour prend b2 donc
ça c'est là c'est une tentative de
défense détiennent mais il sait bien que
quand il récupère quand il redonne sa
pièce vers après qu'elle allait prendre
cette égalité matérielle et bien il n'ya
plus trop d'illusions à se faire tout
reprend g2 tentative un peu désespérée
le seul coup finalement puisque les
blancs aux menaces de mater en quelques
coups oui alors bon menace d'un procès
filmé nasdaq prend m6 ils menacent
d'am-dam et fuite avec un échec à la
découverte brutale oui ils menacent
énormément de choses je crois que cette
position
ça se passe pratiquement dans le rugby
une petite variante marrante ce serait
sur un coup comme bk tout à coup sans
intérêt il y aurait par exemple d'année
fuite échec
je lis la reka value8 seul coup
calais 8 forcé est là dans cette
position il y aurait probablement le
coup jean luc hallé c6 je pense que
c'est ce que tu allais voulu dire qui a
l'air extrêmement puissant tout
simplement
non non on peut jouer peut-être tout
simplement fou oui donc ta variante
finalement elle est pas si ça c'est
clair que ça je pense je pense que tu
t'es un petit nom installé j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé donc on peut trouver
peut-être le coup cavaliers f5 cavaliers
f5 qui ne marche pas d'étonnant alors
non on va en face se calmer sur le coup
b4 il ya simplement jean luc sans aller
chercher plus loin dans cavaliers m6 qui
ramasse une pièce et gagne la partie
ouais c'est vrai que j'ai voulu
j'ai voulu sacrifier j'ai voulu faire
quelque chose de joli oui c'est ton
esprit un petit peu mais tu joues comme
ça tu es partie du gers et c'est
exactement ce que enfin disons que j'ai
eus vlad au téléphone tout à l'heure et
il m'a dit que bon il a pas trouvé de
solution dans ce tournoi et il a essayé
de jouer un petit peu dans mon style
dans cette partie et ça ça a bien marché
tant mieux pour lui donc vladislav imite
jean-luc chavanon s'est tue c'est du
grand jeu sa tour projet derrière
défense détiennent macro tout reprend
tour fou prend donc ça c'est logique
etienne poursuit son idée il essaie de
d'aller en finale en fait ce en limitant
la casse d'un problème si ce jeu
ladislav une pièce de plus son roi
toujours en sécurité donc ici on peut
vraiment dire que c'est terminé
d'un point cette d'un programme
à noter qu'il faut pas jouer jean luc tu
reprends des 4 et leur donniez tout de
suite puisque le foucher 2 qui est en
prise reviendrait sur la case des 5 je
l'avais vu c'est important donc dame
province est roi prend et maintenant on
reprend g2 donc cette finale est
techniquement gagnante
c'est une finale techniquement gagnante
en général quand un fou je joue une
finale contre de pionsat peut être nulle
si les pions sont liés là on voit que la
structure des noirs est catastrophique
on est tous les pions sont faibles
tous les pions seront parsemés donc sur
cet échiquier et les noirs ne vont pas
pouvoir tenir très longtemps alors on va
voir qui tiennent à trouver une
ressource même il a trouvé un piège dans
cette position on va le montrer parce
que c'est assez instructif pour ces
quatre fous des trois attaques à tours
pour ces cinq on défend nos pions roi f3
très logique en finale il faut monter le
roi au centre c'est tout à fait normal
tour h5 fouet fin des fins le curage
trois tours des cinq rois de 4 on va
prendre l'option des quatre métiers du
roi m6 il donne l'option tout à son
époux et à vendre le défend et il
semblerait ici jean luc eux surtout
reprend des cartes ça soit nul
immédiatement alors on va quand même
commenté ça si les bouchoux ce coup qui
semble être une énorme faute il y à tour
prend tour roy prend 0,5 et l'avenant
donc après roanne 3 donc il y a donc le
cou à cette marche ça ne marche pas
quand même ça ne marche toujours normal
idc e5
et si on échange les pions e et f et
bien l'option h3 plus le fouet fin
contre rien pour les noirs c'est nul
voila parce que le fouet fin et en sueur
case blanche la casse de promotion du
pion tour étant de cases noires fou plus
puis en tout ça ne passe pas c'est nul
alors ici pourquoi on dit que c'est faux
et bien tout simplement fait c'était un
faux piège détiennent bacrot il y a le
cou fou des trois échecs et sur roy
bouge on n'échange plus les pions à tout
prix anjou le coup s4 s5
donc c'est même pas vraiment un piège
mais etienne bacrot était un peu
désespéré il voulait vraiment marqué ce
point on le verra d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure dans classe qui colle et donc ça
n'a pas suffi tourbe est un des trois
donc là c'est terminé il commence à
donner les pions il va tous les perdre
de toute façon faut prendre des trois
tours h 5 fois fin on revient vlad l'aï
manche tools et le nettoyeur eux cinq
ils essayent désespérément d'échangés le
pion aux contres pions f mais après tour
combes et 5 il ya un clouage voilà on ne
peut pas prendre le dessus entourage
quatre tours b 6 échecs
le roi doit partir et le roi va pas le
plus simple
le roi veut prendre l'option aux cinq
donc ici vladislav on voit que dans
cette finale les pions noirs étaient
tellement faible qu'il les a tous pris
sans en perdre un seul
oui c'était
c'était assez prévisible assez
prévisible très belles parties de
vladislav quatre chefs qui s'est bien
réveillé qui est bien revenu et donc
tout de suite on va en savoir plus sur
lady slave dans la fameuse rubrique
jean-luc que tu affectionnes cet art
rubrique c'est chasse picole tout de
suite c'est maintenant
qu'est-ce qui paye tout de suite alors
tout sur la vie des stars de l'échiquier
notamment jean-luc au tournoi de
hambourg
et oui tout à fait donc un tournoi de
hong un plein de surprises on a appris
énormément de choses dans ce tournoi
donc là tu t'habilles en rockeur s'est
spécialement pour la rubrique oui tout à
fait d'accord
une grande nouveauté oui donc un rocker
fou puisque les joueurs semblaient assez
décontracté dans ce tournoi alors on va
faire un petit un petit bilan de tout ce
qui s'est passé pendant pendant ce temps
là donc christian donc le joueur
malchanceux christian bauer donc a été
très malchanceux mais il avait quand
même la chance d'être réconforté par sa
petite amie et son petit bébé donc qui a
un mois qui braillaient donc à côté la
salle du tournoi toute la famille est
venue en fait soutenir qu'elle sent
mauvais toute la famille est venue
soutenir christian bauer
il y avait même laurent frayssinet qui
étaient là pour pour tenir les vignerons
pour obtenir le biberon du bébé donc
alors entre ciney laurent frayssinet en
futures mamans et futures mamans voilà
d'autres en ce qui concerne le tournoi
aussi il ya eu deux matches à en dehors
du tournoi donc deux matchs qui se sont
joués il ya eu le match freyssinet
contre bacrot un match à mach resto donc
les joueurs qui ont fait des parts et
des paris sur le tournoi qui ont parié
dès resteront sur des victoires
éventuelle de l'un de l'autre
donc je veux c'est laurent frayssinet
d'ailleurs qui s'en est sorti victorieux
pileux si j'ai bien compris il devrait
être invité quatre fois au restaurant
par etienne bacrot au vu des résultats
finale du tournoi wen lors laurent
frayssinet est sorti vainqueur de ce
match c'est une compensation il fait 4
sur 9 il fait moins bien qu etienne mais
il a quand même gagné le match restos et
anale
il y avait aussi le match laurent contre
joël lautier un match incroyable puisque
les joueurs pour la journée de repos ont
décidé de jouer sur playstation
playstation donc bon laurent frayssinet
est très joueur on le savait joël
lautier
finalement les aussi donkey nos jeux sur
playstation à un jeu de simulation de
voiture est alors ont été très surpris
je me rappelle puisqu'il a dit joël
lautier incroyable au début ils avaient
beaucoup de mal et il a progressé très
très vite
will lautier qui apprend très vite et
qui
il n'avait pas envie d'arrêter la partie
puisqu'ils ont joué jusqu'à 5 heures du
matin la vie des stars
voilà la vie des stars en ce qui
concerne notre playboy national vlad
on peut dire que c'était pas là ce
n'était pas la grande forme pour ce
tournoi puisque on peut dire qu'il en a
qui l'a peut-être un peu trop user de
ses charmes
c'est possible en tout cas on a vu un
vladislav très fatigué sûr sûr sûr se
tourner sur ce tournoi début de tournoi
c'était sérieux il allait courir tous
les matins et ensuite à partir de la
première défaite
eh bien c'était plus tout à fait ça
voilà c'était plus tout à fait ça et
c'était vraiment incroyable
alors pour conclure jean luc eux on a
une on a fait un petit montage d'une
soirée sympathique passés avec les
joueurs d'échecs
donc je pense qu'on va l'envoyer on va
le commenter en même temps que les
images pas ça voilà donc là vous voyez
il s'agit d' etienne bacrot qui vient de
rater un coup sur le billard
et là c'est laurent frayssinet c'est son
adversaire dangereux précis n'est très
très concentré on a vu la petite amie
détiennent dans le fond donc les joueurs
s'amusent ils n'arrêtent pas de jouer en
fait laurent frayssinet c'est le joueur
est là il faut qu'il mette la [ __ ] dans
freyssinet il est très concentré et
loupe l'a87 incroyable leurs oppresseurs
ils oublient les des privés il est
défini l enquête n macro rigolent ils
sont vraiment détendu donc ça c'est
après une partie alors etienne bacrot
acrobatique
tout ça dans une tentative il faut quand
même on peut quand même constater que
les joueurs sont quand même beaucoup
moins fort que michael adams qui lui
tint virtuose donc du billard c'est vrai
la soirée un petit peu dans la couleur
de l'argent avec paul newman sauf que
c'est laurent frayssinet qui vais la
boule numéro 6 jean-luc avec beaucoup de
facilité
là encore laurent à etienne bacrot voilà
c'est là vers un final c'est la dernière
boule il reste plus que les boules
blanches et noires sur le sur le mur at
sur le billard laurent frayssinet même
configuration juste et voilà et c'était
les victimes aulas il l'a eu donc
laurent frayssinet toujours très
expressif quand ils gagnent laurent
frayssinet etienne bacrot match reste au
match et chaque et match billard
vraiment décidément s'arrête pas de
jouer voilà l'on sait c'est extrêmement
quand on leur offre à signer voilà donc
voilà en face et je crois qu'il ya aussi
garry kasparov qui va jouer contre
ternes chapman le match ce week end
voilà un match qui va bientôt commencer
donc garry kasparov qui qui commande là
précisé la sphère va donner deux pions
il a donné deux pions à terrance chapman
et
un petit peu un petit peu sur toutes les
cases de l'échiquier ça va ça va changer
en fonction des parties est bon on vous
en dira plus sur ce mois des recherches
au sénat chargé la semaine prochaine
alors maintenant nous allons conclure
cette émission avec les news en bref
actualité dans le reste du monde comme
chez moustiques donc d'en cerner nas das
hermanas le super tournoi en espagne qui
commence jean luc tu connais ce tournoi
un petit peu c'est traditionnel et c'est
espagnol c'est un très très fort tournoi
je crois d'ailleurs qu'il ya un jeune
espoir
russ radjabov qui joue ce tournoi il est
trop jeune il a 13 ans un des plus
jeunes grands maîtres du monde
donc le taux à dos hermanas et fait
partie des grands classiques du circuit
espagnol
on va exciter les joueurs almasy
radjabov almasy qui le jeune joueur
hongrois il ya il y as mirin grâce à une
coque vallejo jeune star espagnole
également sokolov dryef hazemag par
gillings gourévitch est signé ska le
numéro un espagnol tout ça au tournoi de
dos hermanas ça vient de commencer et
tout de suite le petit et mourad j'adore
jean-luc fait des émules puisque il
avait su tracer le kof on y relate
christophe un joueur expérimenté qui
était arrivé en quart de finale je paie
du monde de groningen il y a quelques
années
7 c'est la révélation puisque ce jeune
joueur n'a que 15 ans c'est un jeune qui
en veut radjabov red bud knock out en
avant' comme tous les ans et bien les
anglais organise un tournoi chaos à
élimination directe
et comme tous les ans serait on tenté de
dire c'est le favori qui l'emportent
michael adams toujours là michael
michael qui fait son grand retour depuis
depuis la coupe du monde où ils avaient
ils avaient échoué malheureusement
contre la la ravissante judith contre la
vie chère qui dit championnat du monde
donc coupe du monde de cannes parties
rapides
adams a gagné la finale 2 à 0 en battant
donc en finale le très bon joueur
anglais très fort joueur dopé n roll
yann auxonne dernière info jean luc
c'est la polémique actuelle entre
garry kasparov et anatoli karpov et
vladimir kramnik qui envoie une lettre
ouverte à d'affidés donc fédération
internationale des échecs pour leur
signifier qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord
avec la nouvelle cadence revue par la
fidh et oui les trois kaki qui ne sont
pas contents donc avec intérêt et oui
ils ne sont pas contents avec un cas
puisque la fidea changer les règlements
ça change régulièrement et ils ont donné
une lettre ouverte peut-être que la
formule actuelle déjà ne plaît pas à
tout le monde et donc tout c'est tous
ces changements récents donc serait
contre leur politique mais c'est pour le
spectacle que la fidh et donc veut
raccourcir la cadence on le rappelle
mais les joueurs ne sont pas
spécialement peau et ça m'a plutôt
contre on sait que les échecs ça se joue
avec beaucoup de réflexion
voilà donc c'est la fin de cette
émission je vous remercie de l'avoir
suivi la semaine prochaine évidemment
tournoi de danse hermanas à la loupe
jean-luc on se donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine et on
kit passion à tous la bonne couleur à
les génériques
vous
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur
diagonale avec ce soir stéphane aborde
pour stephen dans soirée loin alors en
plateau de grève ce soir c'est parce
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on reçoit
autant de grands maîtres sur la table
beaucoup beaucoup de joueurs et pourquoi
et bien tout simplement c'est le grand
prix du sénat qui va commencer dès
demain donc repris du sénat grands
joueurs évidemment nous avons donc
quatre joueurs de d'exception et
d'exception on va commencer par les
présentateurs je commençais à ma gauche
par christian bauer danseurs christian
pour ça alors christian bauer champion
de france en quelle année 96 je crois
oui et aussi participants dernier
dernièrement ou à la coupe du monde
rapide de cannes
voilà c'était vers le 20 mars et bon jeu
j'étais très content de participer à
cette coupe est bon j'essaierai de faire
mieux résultats que canon dont christian
qui avait représenté la france notamment
aux olympiades aux dernières olympiades
où tu tenais le premier échiquier
oui istanbul c'était une très bonne
expérience donc joueurs quand même assez
habitués aux semi rapide puisque je
crois que tu as joué déjà à bordeaux
donc là déjà un premier tournoi semi
rapide en élimination directe également
donc la coupe du monde deux parties
rapides à cannes qui a une excellente
expérience et là encore le grand prix du
sénat voilà oui j'avais aussi fait des
semi rapide assez fort au dernier zonal
monde à riddes qui détermine
éventuellement une place pour qualifier
pour la champions du monde
voilà donc pour christian bauer alors à
sa droite nous avons le joueur mythique
enfin meetic le très très grand joueur
fantastique
champion du monde de 1969 à 1972 on a le
plaisir de recevoir ce soir monsieur
boris spassky bonsoir pour sal alors est
ce parce qu'ils déjà donc je te couper
loin finaliste l'an dernier contre
alexei shirov et savez c'est un bon
souvenir hier lors pas très bonne sur
une île marine date avec ses cheveux
games lors des grosses sommes certes of
fry tonnes de sacs en game we alors donc
rêver mba craintes au niveau du contrôle
d'accès laboris dit qu'au grand prix du
sénat de l'année dernière donc il avait
joué contre shirov en finale a donc
après avoir éliminé arnaud hauchard en
demi finale et là c'était très difficile
dans la mesure où il a perdu la première
partie et dans la deuxième on se
rappelle donc qu'il avait des chances de
revenir avec un système hippopotames
système
et donc finalement ça n'avait pas eu
lieu
donc boris on peut dire que vous revenez
un petit peu à la compétition puisque
vous avez joué le tournoi de cornouaille
et les asbl plutôt fait un bon résultat
puisque vous êtes arrivé à vous
qualifier en quarts de finale elle a
joué contrôle sanguin
battenheim obtenait un beso single show
elle est bonne alors boris dit qu il est
un peu retiré mais enfin ça c'est ce
qu'on verra dans les parties à venir
en tout cas donc ça va être des très
très beau match on l'espère nouveaux
joueurs mais on le connaît déjà il
s'agit du numéro un français depuis plus
de dix ans bon champion du monde junior
en 88 ça fait un bout de temps second au
tournoi d'enghien les bains et atteindre
notre jour d'affichage
bonsoir bonsoir stephen donc figure
emblématique des échecs français depuis
longtemps déjà
tu as joué le grand prix du sénat
l'année dernière et ça s'est pas très
bien passé bon c'est à peu près le même
scénario que pro borisov a sauf que bon
j'avais fait nul après la partie contre
shirov avec les north qui était un bon
départ et puis ensuite dans la deuxième
avec les blancs bon j'ai pris des
risques pour gagner bien sûr et dans les
complications disant quelque chose que
que j'avais manqué il a réussi à gagner
la partie mais bon on ne chante pas j'en
ai pas un mauvais souvenir et puis
j'avais fait un deuxième match ensuite
contraint aux chocs que je vais que
j'avais réussi à gagner donc dans
l'ensemble c'était pas trop mal pas trop
mal donc là en ce moment donc y jouer la
finale du champion de france par équipes
pour le club de clichy bons résultats
non pas vraiment parce que l'équipe
partait largement favorite avant la
phase finale on avait gagné tous les
matches on était la seule équipe à avoir
le maximum de points et on avait deux
matches aux critiques contre cannes
d'abord et contre monaco ensuite et on
les a perdus tous les deux un point donc
bien sûr on est déçu
enfin bon ceci dit ce n'est peut-être
pas si mal qui est un peu de changement
en haut qu'on voit une nouvelle équipe
championne de france ça relance
l'intérêt du championnat donc dans ce
corps individuel
j'avais fait trois sur quatre
fonctionnent à la fois sur quatre pas
mal donc je vais voter plutôt en forme
donc ici le plus gros classement de ce
tournoi peut être donc favoris comme
stéphane oui mais je de l'outil favori
sur le papier en tout cas vis du
classement mais bon on peut dire que les
joueurs se tiennent tous dans une
fourchette de 50 points à peu près donc
ça on ça veut dire que l'image devrait
quand même être assez équilibré c'est
clair derniers joueurs de ce tournoi
mais pas le moindre enfin il s'agit
quand même du plus jeune
un petit peu la mascotte de diagonale
laurent frayssinet concert de rang
bonsoir robe on sort stephen donc grand
maître depuis déjà deux ans tu as
seulement 19 ans tu as nombreux titres
chez les jeunes donc chambre vice
champion du monde cadet tout à fait en
99 il y en a eu d'autres
oui aux vice champions du monde benjamin
en 95 et voilà je vise la seconde phase
en tout cas d'arrêt championnat du monde
s'y est pas si mal mais bon ici bon on
verra
c'est d'ailleurs sur ce 10 mai rapide
donc c'est c'est vraiment faut voir
comment ça se passe au niveau des matchs
je crois qu'on peut pas vraiment donner
de pronostic même s'ils jouaient les un
peu favori par rapport à nous je pense
qu'on est les jouets les un peu favori
un peu au dessus et après on est trois
gros outsider et je crois que ça dépend
vraiment de la physionomie des matches
donc laurent frayssinet en tout cas en
pleine forme puisque il vient de faire
une perte de 1881 sur le dernier
week-end sur l'avant-dernier week-end de
la semaine on parlera pas du dernier
puisqu'il était moins bon mais en tout
cas donc l'auront toujours présente
toujours en forme alors maintenant on va
peut-être aborder un petit débat un
petit sujet c'est sur la formule de ce
format du sénat puisque c'est un système
à élimination directe système coupes et
des parties semi-rapides donc on va
demander un peu aux joueurs ce qu'ils
pensent du semi rapide est tout
simplement s'ils s'estiment plus fort au
moins fort dans cette cadence
puisqu'elle est pas tout à fait pareil
qu'est ce que c'est un semi rapides
c'est fun c'est une partie rapide c'est
une partie rapide c'est une partie
rapide alors la différence avec les
parties et blanc goût de parti officiel
c'est que les partisans que ces deux
heures par joueur pour eux 40 coups donc
si on a beaucoup de bien le temps de
réfléchir là quand même
je pense qu'il parle d'intuitions qui
vient en plus enfin ça les joueurs
nouveaux diront peut-être un peu mieux
peut-être commencer par christian quelle
est la particularité du jeu semi rapides
par rapport au jeu partie langue comme
tu le dit moins de temps pour la
réflexion on se donne des parties d'une
qualité un peu moins bonne mais 20
minutes se permet quand même de faire de
maintenir un niveau de jeu assez élevé
et
il faut se décider plus vite évidemment
donc à l'instinct qui prime un peu plus
comme pertinente pour les spectateurs
c'est beaucoup plus amusant parce que
suivre une partie pendant des heures
c'est astreignant et donc je pense que
globalement je suis assez favorable à
cette formule ne considère plus fort en
partie rapide
je pense qu un peu moins fort encore tir
rapide malheureusement partie rapide
donc un petit peu d'effets avoir pour
christian enfin on sait quand même que
bon il est capable du meilleur du pire
peut-être aussi mais en tout cas capable
de faire de très bons résultats en
partie rapide
alors on va s'adresser à boris spassky
donc boris on n'est pas assez rapide
la pile des quotas est bon on va
traduire vos riddick comme il commence à
être assez âgés bien il joue plus avec
la main qu'en réfléchissant bon mais il
faut dire aussi que vous avez quand même
une grosse intuition une intuition très
développée pour naturellement aller vers
la bonne pièce donc notre semi rapide et
assez s'est adapté voilà vivre avec
quelqu'un est 130 est énorme
j'avais plein de normes cadence octime
des concepts de business
battenheim la pizza prao gosses match
fast d'accord alors bon on va traduire
ce qu'elle a dit c'est tout simplement
une partie longue c'est c'est long et
pénible et on n'a pas ça pas envie de
les jouer
ça me fait souffrir oui tout à fait
alors que le smi rapide c'est plus fun
plus tranquille
joël semi rapide non ce pas une
spécialité mais j'aime bien j'aime bien
les parties rapides c'est vrai que au
public c'est plus intéressant
enfin c'est plus facile à suivre c'est
plus facile de comprendre ce qui se
passe les joueurs aussi je vais
peut-être de manière un peu différente
ils sont peut-être un peu plus relâchée
ils veulent nous sommes peut-être plus
envie d'essayer des choses risque et les
choses qui ne seraient pas d'habitude
parce que quand l'adversaire - temps se
dit qu'il a peut-être du mal à trouver
sur l'échiquier les coûts qui réfute une
idée qui peut être un peu douteuse donc
ça change un peu les données de
du jeu et c'est bien j'ai bien joué en
partie rapide des bons résultats oui
dans l'ensemble ouais ça va c'est pas
trop mauvais disons que c'est à peu près
conforme à mon jeu en partie normale
quoi ya pas de bonnes grosses disparités
laurent thuan les semi rapide donc tu es
un classement on va le rappeler
classement où jesse de 2880 points elo
2810 poil en 2002 a donc sauvé hors de
proportion willy qui est ce classement
et jesse qui est fait par la fédération
bon je sais pas qui c'est qui qui est le
directeur du placement mais il faudrait
qu'ils révisent et c'est à dire j'ai
fait deux tours mais en fait ils ont
comptabilisé seulement deux tournois un
temps où j'ai fait 100 % et un toit où
j'ai fait cet ennemi sur 8 avec une
performance à 2800 mais c'est évidemment
pas mon mon niveau de jeu en semi
rapides et donc moi j'aime bien ça mais
bon c'est vrai qu'il ya des faux jeu
très mal ont sagement je me rends compte
après quand je rentrais en est parti et
il ya des fois où je trouve qu'il joue
plutôt pas mal donc je suis je pense que
je suis assez irrégulier un semi rapides
c'est peut-être parce que je j'ai pensé
d'entraînement parce que je change ou de
kaman très peu et donc c'est vrai que
bon je fais jouer assez détendue et bon
jeu bon j'espère je suis en forme et je
veux faire une bonne partie tu penses
que cette cadence a plutôt tendance à
avantager ou être désavantagés je pense
que ça dépend des fois si je suis en
bonne forme
ça peut avantager et six jeux suivants
pour enfants c'est comme je suis très
irrégulier en semi rapides d'autres
comme je peux pas savoir
eh bien nous verrons ça demain demain
avec donc les parties des premières
demi-finales qui commenceront à partir
de 14h30
stéphane je pense que tout de suite on
va passer au tirage au sort en laine est
quand même un des moments les plus
critiques un tirage au sort leur devant
nous on a une coupe on va peut-être
expliquer quand même un petit peu
pourquoi c'est si important que ça le
cerveau parce que ça va donc déterminé
dans l'ordre des matches et les couleurs
aussi et surtout qui va jouer contre qui
il s'est quand même l'élément très
important donc il ya dans cette coupe
qui n'est pas le trophée du sénat mais
qui est un substitut
pour l'occasion puisque la coupe du
sénat et au sénat c'est normal il ya
donc quatre noms dans la coupe
nous allons demander à l'arbitré donkey
et monsieur thierry parise de venir sur
scène et nous expliquer donc la
procédure
voilà monsieur thierry paris ce qui va
venir s'installer ici
alors donc monsieur l'arbitré quel est
votre rôle dans ce tournoi déjà pour
vous présenter un peu donc dans ce
tournoi mon rôle soit effectivement
d'arbitrer les parties c'est à dire
essentiellement de veiller à ce que le
jeu soit de bonne qualité qu'il y ait en
fait que les partis se déroule de la
façon la plus régulière possible
donc il faut savoir que ces cadences et
rapide se joue quand même sous un
certain stress et au bout d'un moment
plus on arrive vers la fin de la partie
plus je dirais les pièces ont tendance à
bouger de plus en plus vite sur
l'échiquier et même de temps en temps un
volet donc des pièces par du jeu on est
là pour veiller justement à ce que les
conditions restent très très bonne et
donc que les joueurs n'aient pas à se
soucier de problème particulier tout à
fait alors le tirage au sort comment ça
se passe est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
va alors quand on me renvoie comme tout
bon tirage au sort il faut une main
innocente qui va
donc tirer il ya dans cette coupe 4 4
boules qui contient chacune le nom d'un
joueur est donc
le tirage au sort en fait d'un
déterminer les rencontres donc les deux
protagonistes de chaque rencontre
d'accord alors donc on va faire tirer
bat une personne qui ne joue pas donc
stéphanois pour choisir donc qu'est-ce
que question de choisir en premier fait
donc alors le la première boucle qui
m'attire est le premier joueur qui sera
tirée va choisir donc la couleur qui le
qu'il aura lors de la première partie
donc avant de choisir la couleur va
effectivement tirer la deuxième groupe
qui serait qui donnera l'adversaire de
ce joueur
mais le premier joueur aura la chance de
choisir la couleur avec lesquels ils
souhaitent donc je vais voilà donc nous
tirons le premier joueur
voilà qui soit opposé au deuxième que
nous allons donc s'est déboîté après
c'est des bonnes surprises et donc il
s'agit de christian bauer christian
bauer donc l'avantagé d'être pris entre
d'être sélectionné en premier et bien
c'est que christian pourra choisir la
couleur qu'il aura dans la première
partie du match
donc compte relancer le suspense donc ça
sera le premier match demain
oui contre boris spassky à voilà donc
voilà nous avons nos deux adversaires
christian contre boris christian choisir
sa couleur après maintenant on va
demander un d
et un de vos deux rivaux de choisir qui
en fait choisir à sa couleur donc
peut-être christian morisse choisir un
des noms alors voilà le premier joueur
sorti c'est bien c'est joël je vois de
l'hôtel lautier et on va donc vérifier
que les libyens freyssinet bon on va
vous voulez montrer c'est un petit peu
tard mais il y avait bien les quatre
noms différents
et là c'est normalement sans surprise et
loire volanges laurent frayssinet
laurent frayssinet voilà donc alors nous
avons donc christian bauer contre boris
spassky christian qui va choisir la
couleur qu'il aura dans la première
partie du match
oui je préférerais jouer avec humour
pour avec les noirs donc ceci aura les
noirs contre boris spassky demain donc
vous jouerez la deuxième demi finale qui
aura lieu à donc 17h30
au sénat en revanche joël et laurent
joueront à partir de 14h30
donc je crois que c'est jouable qui
choisit toute façon on s'est mis
d'accord avec laurent agrément de
mission dans la moselle était d'accord
ça tout le monde est content oui oui
donc donc j'aurai les noirs la première
partie d'accord donc laurent avec les
blancs contre joël on va peut-être vous
poser 2 3 enfin peut-être une petite
question sur ce choix des couleurs
oui pourquoi choisir les noirs donc
c'est ce qui se fait traditionnellement
parce que si on perd avec l'allemand
après on a les blancs donc on peut
essayer de se refaire
en principe c'est l'opinion générale
d'accor donc tu envisages 17 offert
oui elles ont tellement beau risque
d'avoir les devants dans la première
partie c'est plutôt c'est notre c'est un
avantage aucun avantage c'est pareil non
bon donc pas de pas de problème donc là
bas donc joël et élan était d'accord
ce qui veut donc dire que ils ont des
conceptions qui divergent
oui donc ça veut dire que laurent aurait
choisi les blancs by louis laurent m'a
dit que il était vachement fort et les
noirs donc il m'a dit que donc dans le
cas où ils auraient à choisir ils
prendraient des blancs la première parce
que ce serait beaucoup plus facile
égalisé avec les normes deuxième je dis
pas de problème
d'accord donc oui non mais moi j'ai
c'est vrai qu'il ya un score
catastrophique cet ancien que les blancs
et les noirs j'ai perdu aucune partie
depuis le début d'année donc que je suis
à 100 conférences finalement est donc
finalement me peut-être ma couleur forte
hausse et les mains ok mais c'est vrai
que c'est que c'est embêtant si on
persiste à un premier agrément même
avouer ça c'est sûr donc on va peut-être
rappeler la formule des matches pour
donc donné sur des parties semi-rapides
alors nous aurons donc des partis avec
une cadence de 22 minutes par joueur
mais il ya une petite chose importante
c'est qu'à chaque coup joué deux
secondes seront ajoutées d'accord donc
il y aura donc un match aller retour
donc chaque joueur rencontrera avec une
fois donc les noirs et les blancs
en cas d'égalité nous aurons une
première série de blitz non là c'est un
beat classique c'est à dire cinq minutes
par joueur donc également matches aller
retour
si à nouveau à égalité on a une seconde
série de blitz pareil en matches aller
retour
et si on a à nouveau à égalité en a là
un blitz particulier puisque les blancs
auront cinq minutes et les noirs quatre
minutes mais obligation pour les blancs
de gagner sept adultes y avait moyen de
départager les joueurs c'est à dire
qu'en cas de nul et bien c'est tout
simplement les noirs qui gagne et non en
4 minutes et les blancs 5 les dons pour
impératif de gagner et ça ça ça des
partages de manière obligatoire donc
monsieur thierry paris va tout moyen on
vous donne rendez vous demain pour un
arbitrage choc à sortir de 14h30 au
sénat
et maintenant nous allons passer à la
dernière partie de cette émission qui
sont les interventions du public
puisqu'il y en a sans doute donc des
spectateurs de diagonale qui sont venus
ce soir et qui ont peut-être envie de
poser quelques questions aux champions
qui sont regroupés ici
alors peut-être une première question
voyez alors oui on lui pose une première
question donc les pronostics un petit
peu des joueurs qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
demain qu'est ce qui va se passer
les ouvertures alors donc ça c'est des
questions je pense stéphane que qu'on
aura du mal à demander aux joueurs on va
on va quand même vérifier que les
joueurs ne soient pas d'accord pour en
parler mais laurent est ce que je peux
donner le pronostic sur ton match et
l'ouverture
moi je veux demain mais je pense que je
vais gagner et donc peut-être à 3 ou h 3
h et pages et sites en fait entre les
deux coups donc vous pouvez voir qu'on
prend des cours pour changer les blancs
noirs ouais voilà évidemment joël bats
écoute je sais pas toi sont deux le
match va être va être difficile c'est
sûr mais bon je pense que ces poissons
c'est pas très important de se poser ces
questions dans un match comme ça je sais
pas on verra bien mon fils michael fait
que des machos attendu et puis qu'on
verra bien en ce qui concerne les
ouvertures c'est pareil ça dépendra de
que de nous devait resserre donc et tu
est propice plutôt à jouer aux quatre
des quatre ans quand tu auras livre la
revanche peut y réfléchir
bob the opening notre mode online
d'accord boris pas faire rester calme
donc garder les vêtements trop coeur
tranquille donc pas de pas de
commentaire sur cette question est ce
qu'il ya une autre question
donc on va vous demander de mettre le
micro un peu plus près de la gare de
vous ok et dont la question c'est dire
s'ils avouent qu'ils étaient vraiment
beaucoup on associe son nom à celui des
bougies et ensuite le point sur la
question
quels souvenirs ils gardent des d12 un
compte avec wifi g les chorales ont tout
de suite posé la deuxième question donc
boris
en fait c'est vrai que quelque chose
revient souvent quand on parle de vous
c'est le match parce qu'ils fischer le
fameux match donc reykjavik en 1972 à
propos des deux mots à propos des deux
c'est à dire qu'on associe votre nom à
celui de bobby fischer
est ce que ça vous dérange que votre nom
soit associé à celui de bobby fischer et
donc qu'elle quels souvenirs gardez-vous
de bobby fischer je sais vous allez
embarquer noisette pour un oui à götze
baby famille aristocrate of sky est
conscient qu'ils étaient leaders et
chefs traditionnels les causes probables
fisher price son internement ce monde
afin de chasse got a lot of respecte pas
trop ce qu'ils peuvent faire du skate
tragic d'accord on va traduire tout ça
un petit peu
à la volée donc il a des très bons
souvenirs de bobby fischer pour il
estime que bobby est un joueur qui a
énormément développé le jeu d'échec
puisque donc avant 1970 les échecs
n'était pas encore vraiment reconnu
n'était pas médiatique
il a poussé le jeu les joueurs sont
maintenant mieux payés il ya vraiment un
métier qui a été formé donc il ya des
très bons souvenirs de bobby et qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire il ya une tragédie
parce qu'il ne joue plus aux échecs ça
et aussi pour le mois il atteint les
surprises de ce pli d'accord donc bobine
est un aristocrate d'esprit ouais donc
voilà nous avons une traduction de
bertrand guyard qui n'a pas de micros
mais donc on va c'est pour ça qu'on le
va le reprendre il a pensé qu'elle était
la correction merci non seulement faute
à le passer à une autre question
c'est une autre question oui on peut
revenir peut-être sur ce sujet c'est
vrai que sur les derniers championnats
du monde
une question pour enfin une question se
font revenir dans la caméra oui comment
expliquer qu'il ait de bonnes relations
avec son son opposant bobby fischer
alors que karpov et kasparov se
détestaient alors qu'aujourd'hui
enfin se détester avec très mauvaises
relations ou que la plupart des chefs
des grands champions entre eux avaient
du mal à avoir des relations
quand dirais-je cordiale alors c'est bon
vous avez compris la question un écran
outre le standard poor's
alors pour répondre la première partie
de la question c'est qu'il vaudrait
mieux demander à kasparov et karpov
pourquoi ils ne s'aiment pas et ainsi de
suite mais ma chronique deuxième partie
de la réponse c'est que tout simplement
ses liens avec bobby ont toujours été
très respectueux et très très digne on
va dire ces deux joueurs qui se qui se
respecte est beaucoup une petite
dernière question peut-être dans le
public oui nous avons une question
bonsoir j'ai une question qui s'adresse
à tout le monde
j'aimerais savoir si un jour vous pensez
qu'on peut prouver qu'avec les blancs il
est impossible de perdre alors ça c'est
une question philosophique
je vais peut-être me tourner vers
vers joël quai comme le le professeur de
l'échiquier donc je vais pourra-t-on
trouver un jour que les blancs je me
fends nul bah écoutes je m'étais jamais
posé cette question là on va dire je
pensais qu'on pourrait essayer de
trouver que les bancs gagner mais qui
font nul oui certainement je pense que
ce serait extraordinaire que les blancs
sont un exemple au premier coup quand
même donc je pense que je pense que ça
c'est pratiquement acquis déjà même si
on n'a pas d'ordinateur encore qui nous
permet de le prouver mais en tout cas
mon avis personnel c'est que la position
de départ est complètement équilibré
bien sûr un petit avantage pour les
blancs mais le résultat normal et si le
résultat parfait existe c'est une partie
nulle
c'est une partie nulle on peut peut-être
dérivés très vite sur l'informatique
puisqu'on sait que les joueurs donc très
actif
les jeunes joueurs utilisent énormément
l'informatique énormément l'ordinateur
les bases de données et tout le tout ce
qui s'ensuit les auteurs de l'analyse
j'aimerais savoir si boris
l'informatique vous apporter quelque
chose
bghouri utilisent l'ordinateur il en a
un grand petit donc il est très équipée
informatiquement et en plus donc c'est
de la magie
tout simplement parce que ça lui a
permis de se préparer contre tous les
joueurs qui sont ici
et alors il ya vous avez trop des
faiblesses chez les joueurs que vous
allez rencontrer à
higgins a encore notre fait
ils sont donc très prometteur christian
dumas dit avant l'émission qui n'avait
pas préparé spécialement non plus comme
c'est une cadence rapide sais pas ce
sera pas le même type de réparation mais
bon dans l'informatique est évidemment
très utile mais cette nuit ça va ça va
cogiter ou un petit peu mais pense pas
non plus je d'accord préparation
tranquille pour christian bauer lens il
ya encore une question avant qu'on se
bat encore une question donc le public
est chaud
buscher un mot ça va je veux y revenir
un peu sur bobby fischer je vous
souhaitez demander aux quatre grands
maîtres qu'elle serait à leur avis le
résultat de matches entre le fichant 72
le cas sport offre actuelle c'est une
bonne question ça alors quel serait le
résultat de ce match peut-être loin
franchement si cher de 72 et dans le
fichier que je mangeais pas utilisé en
détail sur son jeu donc je serais pas
capable de le dire évidemment je connais
les parties principales et j'ai regardé
beaucoup de ces partis mais j'ai
vraiment pas étudié son jeu tandis que
je connais bien le classement de
maintenant mais bon je pense que oui je
vous allez très bientôt on va pas me
poser une enfin faire une petite
remarque avant de poursuivre la réponse
il paraît que bobby fischer jouerait sur
internet en ce moment et donc laurent tu
rejoues avec lui mais je sais pas ça
faut peut-être demander à boris si la
cour en ci lui a dit que si bobby
fischer joue sur internet
est ce que vous buvez charge ou sur
internet actuellement et social
c'est pas donc c'est pas sûr parce qu'en
tout cas il ya une terreur qui terrorise
tous les joueurs donc il est bas tous
systématiquement en jouant au premier
coup une ouverture aberrante et tout le
monde soupçonne que ce soit bobby
fischer donc c'était juste à parenthèses
leur antre a eu le plaisir d'affronter
ce fameux guest et donc tu as dis je me
rappelle de cette réponse dans une
interview donnée à libération
fischer c'est fischer j'en suis sûr oui
non mais parce qu'on a discuté avec lui
et qu'il a dit par exemple qu'il a dit a
pint heures qui voit souvent à budapest
que il jouait il joue et intentions il
sait c'est donc bon turris et c'est le
club le club défections internes donc
apparemment ça me nuit il à huningue jeu
et il a battu gray two 10,1 donc
j'appelle ça des trucs et quand même qui
fait partie des 30 meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux donc le fantôme de fisher
terrorise sur internet
voilà donc on va peut-être poursuivre
pour la réponse donc est-ce que fisher
1972 contre kasparov 2001 quel sera le
résultat de ce match ol une analyse
tu veux que je te dirai score exact
c'est le sort difficile comme question
mais dire que le pôle de problème c'est
que le jeu a tellement progressé depuis
ça y est kasparov jo d'une autre façon
on se prépare pas de la même manière je
sais pas ce que donnera main un match
actuelle entre fischer maintenant et
kasparov
ce sera intéressant de voir
on appelle occasions malheureusement
devoir bobby à part lors de son match
contre maurice en 92
et j'aimerais bien qu'ils reviennent oui
ce serait très intéressant de voir mais
bon sur un match hypothétique comme ça
et en plus ça pénalise 2060 non bien sûr
mais enfin quand même c'est ce qui est
c'est la version qui s'en rapprocherait
le plus sous pression
oui bon actuellement je pense qu'il va
beaucoup moins d'énergie aussi quand 72
et que ses connaissances théoriques et
est nettement inférieure à celle de
kasparov actuellement et donc qui
partira avec un gros handicap fois pour
un match hypothétique patrick fischer en
quatre parts of fischer seventy tugend
kasparov n'a iphone ipod touch pourquoi
microsemi pinion espèce par espèce
inconnue et qui a donné chez edf
et puis 15e attaque et pise actifs
gbagbo n est pas sa famille des talents
aubry fléchissement d'être mais c'est
une urne morceaux mais comme alors la
différence entre le jeu de garry
kasparov et de bobby fischer c'est que
kasparov joue extrêmement bien quand il
a initiative mais c'est plus ou moins le
l'unique domaine où vraiment ils
maîtrisent complètement les positions
qu'ils jouent dans les autres domaines
c'est un joueur entre guillemets
conventionnel un super joueur mais assez
conscient alors que bobby fischer lui
avait un style complètement universel
pouvait jouer n'importe quel type de
position de façon exacte est juste et
donc le talent de guy fischer était
supérieur à celui de gary kasparov bien
messieurs une question peut-être plus de
questions n'ont apparemment il n'y en a
plus donc nous allons terminer cette
cette émission rappelant les horaires
les appareils mans
les matchs et compagnie le fond qu'est
ce qu'on tolère tout l'inversé les
matches c'est pour une image de mer se
sera tient alors non pas du tout le
premier match demain c'est entre laurent
qui aura les blancs enfin laurent
frayssinet qui aura les blancs à 14h30
contre joël lautier suivi de la revanche
donc revanche ensuite beast de départage
s'il ya lieu ensuite 17h30 c'est le
match dont christian bauer qui aura les
blancs les noirs dans la première partie
contre boris spassky matches
aller-retour en cas d'égalité on
recommence avec délice de les partager
ainsi de suite
ça sera indirecte continue sur canal web
à partir de 14h30
il y aura toujours l'antenne l'antenne
sera toujours prises il y aura des
reportages sur le match kasparov cram
nic brown games des reportages sur la
coupe du monde surtout les meilleurs
événements couverts par diagonale entre
les parties donc ce sera une émission
complète qui va durer plus de six heures
avec évidemment le superbe grand prix du
sénat qui sera en direct avec les
commentaires de jean luc chavanon qui
est ici d'un public de bertrand guyard
qui est ici également dans le public de
stéphane deux mois et on fera tourner
les maîtres qui seront dans la salle
donc on vous remercie tous d'avoir
participé à cette édition et rendez vous
demain donc voila merci